l'hiver approche et les journées
raccourcissent à vue d'oeil mais un
nouveau parcours nocturne illuminera les
nuits de laval avec illumine série des
lumières par cavalia je foulais 2 les
fans à mon spectacle je voulais des
girafes dans mon événement
je voulais des flammes à route et puis
je ne suis pas d'accord elle s'utilise
suivant alors j'ai décidé de faire des
milliers de sculptures de lumière les
visiteurs découvriront 8 monde composé
de centaines de structures lumineuses de
la savane multicolores au boulevard
américain revisité en passant par les
pots lumineux un voyage féerique et très
instagram abl si une nouvelle façon de
voir le monde me dit que c'est très
immersif des gens créent leur propre
parcours les gestes promènent leurs
propres et le site d'illuminer grands
comme 30 à reynès odeurs qui il a fallu
pour moins de deux mois à 200 employés
pour connecter les 10 milliards dans
paul d'elle la technologie des ampoules
del a été une véritable révolution dans
le domaine le sapin auprès de 200 pieds
de haut et vous avez 24 1000 boul chaque
boule va chercher une couleur différente
indépendant le programme a été monté par
un 2 1 canadiens québécois de montréal
si je veux créer cavaliers où je prends
un corps et du damier chemin c est dans
mon arbre il va apparaître ces aidants
mais 24000 bol je peux faire le jeu de
lumière que je veux pour ce nouveau
projet l'équipe de cavalia a pu compter
sur une aide financière de 2 millions
200 mille dollars de la part de québec
et de tourisme là bas
la popularité des parcours illuminé a
été stimulée par les récents succès de
la compagnie montréalaise même une
facture avec leur série parcours lui
mina ils ont réussi à revitaliser décide
dans plusieurs régions avec leur
parcours immersif et a attiré des
centaines de milliers de visiteurs
[Musique]
le jardin botanique a été un des
précurseurs avec ces lanternes chinoises
qui remporte depuis le début des années
90 un vif succès nous dans notre grosse
saison vraiment c'est septembre octobre
avec jardins de lumière et halloween
c'est vraiment un moment fort dans la
vie du jardin botanique
il ya quelques années on a décidé qu'on
laissait plus l'entrée les parce qu'il y
avait trop de monde s'amusait
l'expérience de visite
maintenant oui effectivement dans des
billets ça arrive très souvent qu'on est
complet en tout cas pour les plages de
débit soirée on est très satisfaits de
l'achalandage avec il eut mis l'équipe
de cavalia espère remporter le même
succès écrit une nouvelle tradition du
temps des fêtes ici nabi alexandre
chartier radio-canada laval